BRIAN KENNISH: Hey everyone.
My name is Brian Kennish.
I'm a developer advocate on the
Google Chrome Team and the name
of this session is, Google
Chrome Extensions How-to.
So I wanted to do a quick
survey here and figure out how
many of you have already built
a Google Chrome Extension.
Well, I see people on my
team raising their hands
which is a good sign.
And how many of you
have built a browser
extension of any sort?
Oh, wow.
Awesome, so a fair
number of you.
Great.
So in this talk I'm going to do
a little intro material, what
Google Chrome Extensions are
and what the extension
ecosystem looks like and then
I'll spend the bulk of the hour
talking about the technical
bits of how you actually
implement these things.
And for those of you that are
already experienced extension
developers I picked some new
extensions as examples and I'm
going to pick them apart and
show you how they work, so
there should be some new
content in there
for you as well.
All right, a couple of
housekeeping items
before I dive in here.
We have a wave channel
available for this talk, which
you can get to you by going to
jump that's j.mp/chrome6.
There's a moderator gadget in
there where you can cue up
questions for me and I will
try to take some of those in
addition to live questions
at the end of the talk.
As a bit of foreshadowing I'm
actually going to be talking
about a bunch about Google Wave
in this talk and how you can
match it up with Chrome.
And the second item is that we
had a suggested hashtag, which
is also chrome6 to use with
your favorite microblogging
service such as Google
Buzz, hint hint.
So I've organized this talk
somewhat along the lines of
a typical programming book.
Like I said, I'm going to
start with some intro.
Then I'm going to do the
canonical Hello World thing
and live code the Hello
World of extension.
Then I'm going to go through a
series of deeper dive technical
topics, So I'll start by
talking about webbiness which
is a fun word to say, but also
extensions happen to be webby
and I'll talk about how so.
Then I will get into
the feature set of
the extension system.
Next I'll talk about HTML5,
which is obviously a big topic
of this years conference and
show you how you can integrate
some HTML5 features
in your extensions.
Then I'll talk about the
experimental stuff that were
tinkering with in the extension
system and finally like I said,
we'll do some Q and
A, time permitting.
So this thing is awesome,
but I'm going to go over to
the podium to drive now.
So what are Google
Chrome extensions?
So you already know what
browser extensions are of
course, they're programs,
usually small that add some
features to the core feature
set of the browser.
If your browser has a healthy
extension ecosystem it means
that there are thousands of
these extensions of these
optional features that
are available to users.
So essentially you can create
your own custom browser.
So all of us are running
Chrome, we all have different
sets of extensions installed.
Essentially, we all have a
different and unique browser.
When it came time to design an
extension system for Google
Chrome, of course, we wanted to
apply some Chrome like thinking
to how extensions should work.
So we made it so that Chrome
extensions are simple,
stable, and secure.
In terms of simplicity, as I
hope I'll show later extensions
are really easy to create.
They're also simple in
terms of the UI that
they present to users.
So Chrome is obviously a
very streamlined browser.
Even the name, Google Chrome is
an ironic play on the fact that
there isn't much
browser chrome.
And we want extensions to
work in the same vein.
So our goal is to give
extensions all the UI that
they need to do what they
want to do, but no more.
In terms of stability, you
probably know that webpages
in Chrome all run in
a separate process.
So they can only have a limited
impact on the overall browser
performance and we do the
same thing with extensions.
So each extension will run its
own process and a poorly
performing extension can only
have a limited impact on the
browser performance as a whole.
And in terms of security, we
make it so that extensions have
to be really clear about
declaring their permissions
within the browser to users.
We've also worked hard to
isolate regular webpages from
the extension system so that
it's very difficult for a
malicious webpage to gain the
extra privileges that
an extension has.
And then we have a gallery
for extensions, which
I'll pull up here.
So this is our
extension gallery.
We also tried to do some Chrome
like things with the gallery.
We want it to be really fast
for developers to get their
extensions live and
available to users.
So almost all extensions are
automatically reviewed and
approved and literally
available to the entire Chrome
user base within minutes.
We also want to make it easy
for users to stay up to date
with the extensions that
they've installed and since
there's nothing really easier
than automatic we've made it so
that extensions that are in the
gallery can auto-update just
like Chrome itself
auto-updates.
So as a developer you add a new
version of your extension into
the gallery and users, once
they're online get it
within a couple of hours.
Now I want to talk about the
health of the Google Chrome
extension system and
show you some numbers.
The gallery the I just showed,
we launched back in December,
almost 6 months ago.
And we were really blown away
by the fact that on launch day
developers who up to that point
just had access to the
extension system in the Chrome
dev channel had already
uploaded more than 300
extensions to the gallery.
We continue to be blown away
by how many great extensions
developers have been creating.
On average we're getting more
than 750 new extensions
uploaded to the
gallery every month.
If you think about that that's
actually more hours than there
are in a month, so on average
every single hour a non
Google developer is adding a
new feature to Chrome.
It's pretty amazing.
The usage numbers of Chrome
extensions have been
equally impressive.
More than 10 million extension
installs are happening
every month.
And that represents more
than 15% of the total
Chrome user base.
So more than 15% of Chrome
users right now have at
least one Google Chrome
extension installed.
All right, so let's talk about
some technical stuff now.
So I should give you the caveat
that I am the world's worst
typer, but extensions are so
simple that I thought it'd be a
shame not to do some live
coding and show you how
easy it is to create an
extension from scratch.
If you see me make mistakes
though don't be afraid
to call them out.
So I've given myself
a set of steps here.
So step one to creating a
Google Chrome extension,
we just create a
plain, old directory.
So I'm going to navigate to my
desktop here and I'm going
to create a new folder.
And since we're doing a
Hello World I'm just
going to call this hello.
There we go.
Already a typo.
And I'm going to open
up this directory.
That's step one.
Next I'm going to create
something called
a manifest file.
So I'm going to go back
to this directory and
create a new text file.
And the manifest file is the
one file in the extension
system that has to have a
particular name and that
name is manifest.json.
Then I'm going to pull this
file into my text editor.
I'm just using an
ordinary text editor.
I could literally be
using anything here.
And as you've probably already
deduced from the name this
is a JSON formated file.
And the manifest file is a
descriptive file that tells
the extension system all
about your extension.
Things like its name, what
permissions it has within the
extension system and pointers
to its other components.
So I'm going to create a
JavaScript object here and
then I'm going to give it
a series of required and
optional properties.
So the first will be a name and
I'm going to be real clever
here and call this hello I/O.
Next I'm going to give
it a version string.
And I'm just going to
give this a value of 1.
So this version string is
actually a key piece of data.
I mentioned earlier that
extensions can auto-update and
this is the mechanism by which
the extension system does that.
So it'll examine the version
string of the extension and
it'll know whether or not
an update needs to occur.
Next I'm going to give this
extension a description.
And I'll just say, I like
to say hi and try to
spell that right.
And then I'm going to give
it a series of icons.
So this will be used at various
points by the extension system.
This is going to take a hash.
The first one is going to
be a 48 by 48 pixel icon.
And this is used on the
extension management page.
We'll look at that
in just a second.
And the next will be
128 by 128, which gets
used at install time.
And then finally I'm going to
give this extension some UI and
the UI I'm going to use is
called a browser action.
This is also going
to take an object.
I'm only going to partially
fill this in for now because
I want to get this extension
to a runnable state.
So I'm going to add
a default icon.
So browser action is a little
piece of UI that appears in the
Google Chrome toolbar and it
can take an icon up to 19 by 19
pixels, so I'm going to give
this things a 19 pixel icon.
And I should be good
to go for now.
So I'm going to save this.
All right, one more thing
I have to do before I run
this us add those icons
that I just specified.
So you guys probably don't want
to see me mess with stuff in
Photoshop for the next 30
minutes so I premade these.
I'm going to go back to
my desktop here and I'm
just going to copy these
icons into my folder.
All right, at this
point I should have a
runnable extension.
Let me just clean
up a little here.
So I'm going to go to a new
browser window and I'm going
to go to the extension
management page.
And open developer mode here
and I'm going to say load
unpacked extensions.
This extension is unpacked
because it's not all
packaged for users yet.
And I'm going to navigate
to the folder I just
created and say, OK.
And boom, there we go.
So we've created an
extension here.
Now you can see here
is the browser action
that I just created.
Let me zoom in there for you
since it's a little small.
This is that 19 by
19 pixel icon.
Now you can see if I click on
this thing, which is what I'm
doing now, nothing
actually happens.
So I managed to create a Hello
World program that does
everything except
say, hello world.
So let me actually add in
that Hello World part.
So to do that I'm going to
create a popup and this is
going to be a piece of UI that
appears when a user clicks
on that browser action.
I'm going to go back
to my folder here and
create a new file.
And I'm going to call
this popup.html.
And before I can actually
use this I have to point
to it in my manifest file.
So I'm going to add a
couple more things into my
browser action UI here.
The first is going to
be a default title.
This is going to be a tool tip
that will appear when the
user mouses over the
browser action icon.
And I'll just say, click
for a special message.
And then I'm going to add one
more thing, which is that popup
file that I just created.
So I'm going to say popup
and point to popup.html.
And then I'll save here.
So this popup file is just
an arbitrary html file.
I'm going to drag
it into my editor.
For those of you that are big
proponents of valid html you
might want to look away for the
next 2 minutes and plug your
ears because I'm not going
to concentrate on that.
So I'm just going to create a
very simple html file here.
I'm going to create a
paragraph, give it a little
style and say white
space, no wrap.
Just so this thing
doesn't break.
And I'm going to say my hello
world thing here and close
out that paragraph and
I should be good to go.
So I'm going to save this.
Now all I have to do to see the
results in my change is go to
my extension management page
and reload this extension.
Expand this here.
Now you can see when I
mouseover it I get that
tool tip that I created.
And when I click, voila,
we have our Hello World.
So now we're done
with our extension.
I could stop there, but since
we have this nice gallery let
me go ahead and actually
upload this to the gallery.
So to do that I just hit
publisher extensions
in the gallery.
I'm going to log-in to my Gmail
account and I'm going to
click add a new item here.
So this takes a zip file.
So I'm going to just zip us
this directory that we created.
So we now have the zip and
I'm going to choose a file.
I'm going to navigate over
to it and hit upload.
Now at this point I could add
some nice text that describes
the extension, some
pretty icons.
Maybe even a video that shows
you how to use it since it's
very complex, but I'm not
going to do that for now
for time considerations.
I'll just go ahead
and publish this.
And say, yes.
So for those of you that have
laptops with you-- uh oh, I
have to specify a
language here.
Let's try that again.
As I was saying, for those of
you that have laptops you can
actually go into the extension
gallery now, which is that
chrome.google.com/extensions
and download this
awesome extensions that
we just created.
All right, so I originally
concluded this slide with a
little joke here, but the thing
is we launched a web store
yesterday as you guys probably
all know and soon you'll be
able to sell your apps
including extensions online and
it'll be really easy to
actually make money
00:17:43,5 --> 00:17:43,3
from your apps.
Of course, even last week you
could make money from your
extensions, but our goal with
this web store is to really
reduce the friction for
developers making money.
Doing things like collecting
money from different countries
and in different currencies is
not easy and we want to take
that burden on for developers,
so this is a nice thing to
have if you're interested in
monetizing your extensions.
So next I'm going to go
through that series
of technical topics.
And I'll start by talking about
well, if you only take
one thing away from this
presentation I think it should
be this fact, which is
extensions are webpages.
It is a little bit of an
oversimplification, so I'm
going to correct this
slightly to say extensions
are mostly webpages.
And the reason I say that this
is the most important nothing
to take away from this talk is
that you already know how to
develop webpages, therefore you
already know mostly how
to develop extensions.
So in particular, just like
webpages, extensions are made
out of standard web technology.
So html, CSS, JavaScript
and so forth.
Pretty much anything that you
can get Google Chrome to
render, images, Flash movies,
Java Applets and so on, you
can put into your extension.
Secondly, as we just saw the
development and debugging
process is very similar for
extensions and webpages.
So when you're developing your
extension you just edit it
in any text editor, save
your changes and reload.
Just like you do
with a webpage.
In the same way you can use
Google Chrome's developer
tools to debug.
If you haven't used Google
Chromes developer tools at all
or haven't used them for
awhile, they've gotten
extremely powerful in the last
6 months and I highly
recommend them.
I'll show you some tricks
that you can do with
them in a little bit.
And finally, extensions have
access to all the other handy
APIs that webpages
have access to.
So you can use DOM to traverse
and manipulate your extensions.
You can use XHR to make cross
origin requests, which
we'll look at in a second.
Since extensions don't have to
be cross browser compatible you
can use more cutting edge
features that are only
available in some browsers, you
know obviously Chrome.
Things like HTML5, which
we'll talk about later.
There's amazing amount of HTML5
features packed into Chrome.
You can also use WebKit
vendor experiments.
There's some really nice CS
things in particular for doing
filters and animations.
And finally, the V8 JavaScript
engine that Chrome uses has a
built-in JSON library, which is
very nice if you're doing
any kind of XHR work.
You can just parse and string
a file without having to
pull in any extra code.
Now I said extensions are
mostly like webpages.
Here's the part that's
not covered by mostly.
There are some extra things
that extensions can do that
a regular webpage can not.
The first thing is that
extensions as we've seen,
have some more access
to more UI surfaces.
The first, which we've already
looked at is that browser
action, which is this icon that
installs in the Chrome toolbar.
And like we saw it can
optionally have a
popup attached to it.
Next we have a page action,
which is an icon of similar
size, but unlike a browser
action which appears in the
Chrome toolbar and always
appears on every single tab
that the user has, a
page action appears in
the Chrome omnibox.
And it can appear selectively.
So it can be toggled on and off
depending on the page that
the user is visiting.
And this can also have a
popup attached to it.
Next we have content scripts,
which are similar to grease
monkey or user scripts.
They let you inject arbitrary
CSS and JavaScript into any
matching page that you want to.
And then we have a bunch of UI
surfaces that are not available
in all versions of Chrome yet.
I'll start with the ones that
are most available and move to
the ones that are
lesser available.
The first is desktop
notifications.
So this is available everywhere
except in the stable
channel of Chrome.
It will be available, actually
let me clarify a little bit.
So desktop notifications you
can use in every version
of Chrome right now.
There's a special hook into the
extension system where you
don't have to explicitly ask
the user for permission every
time you want to show an
extension that isn't yet
available in the stable
version of Chrome.
But it's available everywhere
else and it will be available
in the next stable version.
So these are little info
bubbles that appear on the
bottom of the user or
top of the user screen.
Next we have a couple of
experimental UI surfaces.
The first is infobars, which
are the things you see for
example when you enter a
password into Google Chrome and
it asks you if you want to
remember, save your password,
which you saw earlier when
I plugged in my password.
So you can actually initiate
these and generate
these on your own.
And we also have an
experimental context menu
future that lets you add items
to the users context menu.
Next we have three special
components that an
extension can have.
The first we already saw,
it's a manifest file.
Next an extension can have a
background page, which is a
page that runs for the entire
lifetime of the extension, but
it's not shown to the user.
It's useful for doing things
like coordinating tasks if
you have a complex extension
or remembering state
that sort of thing.
We'll look at some background
pages in a little bit.
And finally, you can have an
options page, which lets you
give the user the ability to
configure your extension.
Next we have a set of
privileged APIs that
extensions can hook into.
This is a cool diagram of the
extension APIs that a non
Google developer created.
So there are four APIs for
doing things in the browser.
Things like manipulating
Windows tabs and then history
and bookmarks as well.
And then we also have four APIs
that are extension specific.
So they let you manage
your browser actions
and page actions.
We also have a utility class
for sending messages within an
extension and we had an i18n
class for localizing
your extension into
different languages.
So I should say that
automatically your extension
gets this Chrome object and all
of these APIs are modules
underneath that Chrome
object that you can
automatically access.
All right, so next I want to
take a look at some examples
that implement this stuff.
And I've put together some
these cases of things
that you might want to
do with extensions.
The first I'm calling
the notifier pattern.
This is quite a common
pattern for an extension.
So the scenario is you have
some sort of data that
you want to manage and
display for the user.
It could be local data.
For example, you might want to
keep track of how much the
users is spending on the
internet and showing it to them
or showing them what pages
they visit most often.
But more likely it's going to
be some kind of remote data.
A good example of this would be
one of the more popular
extensions is the Gmail checker
which shows you a count
of your unread messages.
So once you have this thing and
what we're talking about here
is generally smallish data that
you could display with a few
characters or a number.
You're going to want
to show some kind of
counter to the user.
And further you might want to
add some more details, so if a
user initiates some click on
the counter you can show
them additional details.
So the way we can implement
something like this is first
to pull down data we can
use cross origin XHR.
So the Chrome extension
system lets you make
cross origin requests.
I should probably explain XHR.
For those of you that aren't
familiar with this XHR
is XML HCP request.
It's sort of the flux
capacitor of AJAX.
It's what makes AJAX possible.
So once you have this data in
order to display it we can
use something called a
browser action badge.
So this is a little piece
of UI that I didn't
talk about earlier.
You can overlay some characters
automatically on top of
your browser action badge.
These characters are variable
with font so you can fit
somewhere between 4 and
6 characters in there.
So it's good for things like
showing a number especially or
small amount of written text.
And finally we can attach a
popup to this so that if the
user clicks on our browser
action badge and wants more
information we can show them
more information about the
items that we're displaying.
So the example extension that
I'm going to show here, I'm
going to navigate back
to the gallery here.
And I'm going to show you this
Google Wave Notifier that
we just released yesterday.
We worked in tandem with
the Wave team on this.
They've created a new
JSON-based API that lets you
get a snapshot of a users inbox
provided that they authorized
you to do so and I'm going
to install this thing.
You'll notice that it's telling
me what permissions this
extension has first of all.
And you'll see that it added
this browser action badge here.
Right now it's grayed out
and has a question mark.
I'll zoom in there so you can
see it a little bit better.
And I'm taken to an
oauth page here.
So I'm going to go through
the typical oauth dance
and authenticate here.
Once I hit grant access here if
you pay attention to the badge
up here it's going to change
colors, animate, and then it
will eventually show the count
of my unread Wave messages.
So there we go.
It's now in color and I see
that I have 7 unread Waves.
And I can click on this
thing to show those Waves.
I'm seeing 5 of them
by default here.
I can actually configure it
so it shows me all of them.
If I go to the options page
here I can say show me up
to 20 and then I'll see
all of my Waves here.
That's basically a pretty
common pattern among
extensions, so let's
take a look at how this
thing is implemented.
First we'll talk
about the XHR part.
I'm going to start by pulling
up the manifest file here.
And this looks pretty similar
to the manifest file that we
created even though this is a
much more complex extension.
One thing that's new in here
is this permissions property.
So the first thing that we have
in here is the tabs permission.
For some of the APIs, those
privileged APIs that I talked
about they require some extra
permission and the tabs
API is one of them.
So we're using the tabs
API in this extension
to create new windows.
For example, that oauth page
opened up a new window
in the users browser.
We need the tabs
API to do that.
Also, when you click on those
Waves in the popup it'll open
up the Wave client and a new
tab and we need the tabs
API to do that as well.
In terms of XHR we have these 2
URLs specified here and this is
telling the extension system
that we're allowed to make
cross origin requests
to these URLs.
So inside our extension could
we would just make, once we had
those permissions, we would do
XHR work just as we
normally would.
Now I'm not going to show it to
you in this extension because
it's kind of buried in a
library, but I'll point you to
the library that it uses
because it's quite useful if
you're doing any oauth work.
We provide this oauth
library that makes doing
oauth quite simple.
So there's not a whole lot
of knowing of what the
bits and pieces of
oauth are to use this.
You can just use it
pretty seamlessly.
So next let's talk about how we
go about, once we have this
data pull in how we go about
actually displaying
it for the user.
So I'm going to open this
library file where the
displaying is done and we have
a function in here where we set
our browser action badge.
And the first thing that we do
it is we set a color on that
badge and we do this by calling
the chrome.browseraction API
and using a method called
set badge background color.
That just takes a color
property, which is an
array of RGBA values.
And then we have another
function in here for actually
setting the badge text.
This is that same API and we
call the set badge text method,
which takes a text property
and then a string.
And that's how we
set the badge text.
Finally, we have this popup
that we display when
the user clicks on the
browser action badge.
Look at how that's implemented.
So a common pattern that I
often do when I'm creating
these popups, especially things
that are displaying a lot of
data, as you can see this is
all the HTML for the
popup, is that I'll
just create a template.
So here I have a template
called Digest, which
will contain each of
those wave digests.
And it has two pieces of
data within it, a title
and then a snippet.
You can see that I've given
this an ID of template.
Then if we go over to my CSS
here all I'm doing is making
that template invisible.
So when I'm actually ready to
use the template I'm going to
gather all my data together and
like I said, this is a frequent
pattern that you'll do.
You're going to loop through
your data and populate
that template.
So here we have our loop for
going through the data and then
here's the key piece of code
that takes that template.
You can see that it clones it
right here and then it appends
the clone to the
body over here.
And then once we have that
template appended to the body
we just populate it with our
data and we just keep doing
that over and over again
in that [? array. ?]
So it's a really nice way to
have a very small amount
code and easily fill up
a large amount of data.
So the next use case that I'm
going to show you I call
the Detector Pattern.
It's also a frequent thing that
we see done with extensions.
So the scenario here is that we
want to figure out if pages
that the user is navigating to
contains some piece
of key data.
So we'll do some matching
against the pages that
the user goes to.
And then we just wanted to do a
simple indicator saying that
yes or no that data does
or does not exist.
The way we can do this is
with the content script.
So we'll inject the content
script into all the pages that
the user navigates to and then
we'll do some examination
on those pages.
And once we determine that one
of these pages has the content
that we're looking for we
can send a message to a
background page and say
put up a page action.
So as a reminder a page action
was that small icon that
appears in the Google
Chrome omnibox and can
be toggled on and off.
So let's look at an
example that does this.
I'm going to open up a new
tab here and I have this
00:34:19,338 --> 00:34:19,278
extension bookmarked.
So this is a sandwich
detecting extension.
Very important, especially
if you're hungry.
So I'm going to install this.
And what this expansion will do
is that when I navigate to a
page that's talking about
sandwiches it's going to show
me an icon like this that
you see right here.
That indicates there's
sandwiches being talked
about on that page.
So I'll start out by doing
a Google search for
let's say, puppies.
And you can see nothing is
appearing in my Chrome omnibox
here, which is a good sign.
It means people aren't
making puppy sandwiches.
If I searched for roast beef on
the other hand, there we go.
We get our sandwich icon,
so this page is talking
about sandwiches.
Let's see how this
thing is implemented.
So I'll start by looking at
our manifest file here.
We're going to see another
new thing in here, which
is that we are specifying
a content script here.
And we give it a couple
of match patterns.
You can see that these are wild
cards indicating that our
content script will be injected
into every http and every https
page that the user
navigates to.
And then we're specifying
a JS file here.
We could also specify a
CS file if we wanted to.
It's not an either/or.
You can inject both and even
inject multiple JavaScript
and CSS files into any page.
And we're specifying a file
called contentscript.js.
So I'm going to
pull that up next.
This is the file that's
actually going to
do our detection.
You can see it's a
very simple file.
We have a regex here, which
probably not surprisingly is
just a sandwich in there.
If the regex successfully
detects that match we run a
little function here and the
function we run is
send a request.
So content scripts don't have
as much permission as other
parts of other extension
components have and we do
that for security reasons.
So in order for us to actually
display some UI we have to send
this information that the
content script has gathered to
another part of the extension.
In this case we're going to
send it to a background page.
So this function here,
which is in that utility
chrome.extension API, it's
called send request.
It's going to broadcast a
message and then other
components within our
extensions can listen for
that message if they want.
So next I'll open up
our background page.
In this particular extension
here's the component that's
doing the listening.
So we're gonna install
a listener here.
Again, by using that
chrome.extension API.
And you can see we have a
callback function called on
request, which will be
triggered when the
event happens.
And here's that function.
So we just have a simple method
call-in here to the page
action API and it just says
show in the current ID.
Sorry, in the current tab.
That's all there is to that.
So next I'm going to
talk a little bit and
HTML5 integration.
So I've listed out some of the
most useful features or some of
them in any case of HTML5 that
you might want to pull
into your extensions.
I won't go through them all
because I think we're a
little short on time.
I want to leave a little
time for questions.
We have obviously and I should
say when I say HTML5 what I'm
really referring to is HTML5,
CSS3 and the new JavaScript
APIs, so that collection of
new open web technology.
So we have some new HTML5
tags that are available.
There are also some really
nice new CSS properties,
filters, and animation.
And then there's some
JavaScript APIs for doing
things like persistence.
We're going to look at an
example of this as well
as doing notifications.
There's a whole lot more
of these I just wanted
to give some examples.
And when it comes to using
these things in your extensions
since like I said, extensions
are webpages you can just use
this all seamlessly just like
you could in a regular webpage.
For a couple of these features
there are some little
extra hooks into the
extension system.
So for example, things like
desktop notifications require a
permission and we give a hook
into the extension system so
that you don't have to
explicitly ask the user for
permission, you just do
it one time at install.
So let's look at an example
of implementing some
HTML5 features.
I call this the
pushier-notifier pattern
because I didn't really have a
good name for it, but we looked
at some notifiers already.
The scenario here is that
maybe we want to do some
notifications with a
little more information.
Something beyond just a
few characters of text.
A good example of this would
be if you're doing some
kind of news site, you
want to show news alerts.
And maybe we also want to
let the user configure
these notifications.
So determine how frequently
they can appear or
what they look like.
That sort of thing.
And then finally, let's persist
these notifications of
these settings rather.
So in order to do this
we're going to use
desktop notifications.
Like I said, any webpage can
use desktop notifications.
There's a special hook for
extensions to use them though.
And we're going to
add an options page.
We already saw an options page
before, but we're going to look
at how this one is implemented
that lets the user do some
configuration on
these settings.
And finally we're going to use
web storage, specifically local
storage to save these settings
so that they run across
browser sessions.
So even after the user closes
their browser the next time
they fire it up it will still
remember these settings.
So for this particular example,
it's not in the gallery like
the other ones I've been
showing you because it won't
work for all users yet.
So I'm going to load it as
an unpacked extension.
And you'll see immediately when
I load it it pops up this
desktop notification here.
Doesn't say a whole lot, it's
just a demo and we also have an
options page attached to this,
which I'll open up here.
Just let's us set a couple
of things about this.
So we can set how frequently
the notification will appear.
By default this thing is going
to appear every minute and we
can toggle it on or off here.
So I'm going to reload this
extension a couple times so
it shows more notifications.
You can see what it looks like
in that case and I don't want
to wait a couple minutes do
that so I'm just going to
reload here and show a
couple more notifications.
You can see those here.
These notifications will stack
up I believe up to 5 of them
will show and then they'll just
cue up behind the scenes and as
you close them a new
one will appear.
So I'm going to go back to this
option page and disable this
thing because I don't want it
to keep showing up while I'm
showing you code and I'll also
close a couple of these here.
All right, so let's see how
this thing is implemented.
First, we'll start with
our manifest file again.
And again, looks pretty similar
to our other manifest files.
One thing that we've
added here is this
notification permission.
So if you've seen notifications
in the wild before, you've
probably noticed that when you
go to a webpage that wants to
show you a notification you get
an infobar that says hey, is
it OK for this webpage to
show you notifications?
But you didn't see that with
this extension and the
reason is because of this
notifications permission.
I mentioned this
briefly earlier.
This is not yet available in
the stable channel of Google
Chrome, but it's available
everywhere else and it
will be available in the
next stable version.
So once we have that
notifications permission
we can just go ahead
and show notifications.
So I'm going to open up this
background page, which
does the notifying.
And you can see here we have an
if statement that tests to see
whether the notification
is active.
That's a setting that we'll
look at in a second.
And if it is active it
calls this show function.
Let's look at that
function now, here it is.
You can see these
notifications.
I'll zoom in again.
They display a little time
and we just calculate
the current time here.
And then we create
a notification.
We do this with a method
called webkitnotificati
ons.createnotification.
And we just supply a
couple of properties.
This notification happens to
be a standard notification.
You can also do HTML
notifications.
Instead of just supplying text
like this we could actually
supply a HTML file and
completely take over the
rendering ourselves.
And then once we've created our
notification object all we do
is call show on it and
that'll display it.
One more thing that I want
to look at here is this
options page that I showed.
So you'll see this is a very
simple HTML file here.
And like we saw there
are just a couple of
form inputs in here.
We have one, a checkbox for
determining whether or not
the notification is active.
And then we have another for
setting how frequently those
notifications will appear.
We just attach event handlers
to each of these options and
you'll see that when this thing
is triggered what we do is we
save the value into a
local storage object.
So local storage is
another HTML5 like API.
By default, every page
will have a local storage
object available to it.
And you just treat it
like a regular object.
So we're setting a property
called is activated on
the local storage object
and giving it a value.
Down here you'll see we're
setting a property called
frequency and giving it the
value of that input field.
Then if I go back to our
background page here we can
just seamlessly use these
values as if they were
declared in this page.
So if I want to test the value
of the is activated field I
just say local storage
is activated.
If I want to look at
frequency I just say
00:46:15,498 --> 00:46:15,238
localstorage.frequency.
Couldn't really be simpler.
All right, so I'm going to
wrap up here by talking
about our experimental APIs.
Let me close this notification.
We currently have 5
experimental APIs.
We'll just list them
out here quickly.
So our philosophy with respect
to APIs is that we want our
APIs to be very stable once
they're fully available, but we
also want the ability to play
with stuff and have users give
us feedback and suggestions.
And we do that by
creating experiments.
These experimental APIs.
So we have stuff for doing
infobars, context menus,
managing the clipboard as well
as cookies and processes
within the browser.
So in order to use these
experimental APIs there's
a couple of tricks
that you need to do.
The first is that you have
to be using a dev channel
build of Google Chrome.
And then you have to start-up
the browser with this
experimental flag, it's called
enable experimental extension
APIs, very difficult to say.
And then finally you'll just
add an experimental permission
to your manifest file and that
lets you plug into these
experimental APIs.
So let's look at an
example of that.
Again, since this is not fully
available I'm going to be
loading an unpacked
version of this.
Actually, I should probably
run through my little
use case here.
So the scenario that we're
going to be talking about is
that we want to take content
from one page and import
it into another app.
Maybe we're viewing that
content or editing it and we
can either put this into a new
window or tab or just load it
directly into that
current window.
The way we can do this, we
can use the context menu.
So we can make it so that the
user right clicks or the
equivalent on some kind
of resource on a page.
We can grab that and
pull it into our app
using context menu.
And then we're going to use the
Windows or tabs API to make it
so that we open a new window or
reload the contents of
the current window.
Again, let me go back here
and install this thing.
So you guys probably saw during
our keynote the amazing Mugtug
Darkroom app, which is
a photo editing app.
This is an extension that they
are experimenting with in
conjunction with that app.
It'll let me go to any page.
I'm going to do that puppy
search again and let
me look at images.
So it's going to add a
context menu item for when
I right click on an image.
So if I happen to click
somewhere else you'll see
there's nothing special in my
context menu here, but if I
click on one of these images I
now get this edit in darkroom
option and I can click on that
and it will open that image
in the darkroom app.
That seemed not to work,
so let me try that again.
Well, let's pretend
that it works.
It worked earlier, trust me.
It is experimental though.
Let's see how that's
implemented.
So we're going to start with
the manifest file again.
This is really simple
to implement.
So as I mentioned, for using an
experiment API, all you do is
add this experimental
permission.
And then this extension has a
background page that will
actually make the call to
the context menu API,
which is right here.
It's calling this create
function and then we give it
the title of the menu item,
which resources to operate on.
In this case images and then
we have a callback function.
So in that callback
function we're reloading
the current tab.
Again, we're using
the tabs API.
It's loading up there URL and
passing in as a parameter the
image that was clicked on.
That's a quick example
of what you can do with
the experimental APIs.
I should note that when you're
building an extension that uses
experimental APIs you can't
actually upload them
to the gallery.
That's why I downloaded
a local copy.
So these are more for tinkering
with stuff, trying out future
stuff and especially
giving us feedback.
We love to hear feedback
on these APIs.
That's why we put
them out so early.
All right, so now I'm going
to take some questions.
I just want to show you
a couple of resources
that we have.
So all the code that I showed
and I went through it pretty
quickly, but if you want
to examine it in more
depth it's all online.
The Wave notifier you can get
to by going to j.mp/wavecrxsrc
and all the other extensions I
showed you can get to buy
going to j.mp/crxsrc.
And finally, we have some
additional resources that are
really helpful as you get
started writing extensions.
If you're goingt to start
anywhere definitely go to the
docs at code.google.com/
chrome/extensions.
These other resources, the
discussion group and blog
are linked to from there.
And again, here's our Wave
back channel and our hashtag.
So I have about 5 or so
minutes for taking questions.
And I'll take a live question
first and then I'll look in the
moderator and see if there
are any questions in there.
So any questions out there?
00:52:23,894 --> 00:52:23,85
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are there any gotchas
to using standard JavaScript
libraries like jQuery or other
things in your plug-ins?
BRIAN KENNISH: Yeah,
great question.
One thing that I didn't talk
about is that we have this
concept in the extension system
called isolated worlds where we
run content scripts in a
separate execution environment
then the JavaScript
environment on the page.
We do this for a
couple of reasons.
One is security.
I talked about regular webpages
being walled off from the
extension systems, so
this helps us with that.
But we also do it
for compatibility.
So for example, let's say
that webpage is running
one version of jQuery.
And your extension is running
another version of jQuery.
They're not compatible
with each other.
That could potentially cause a
conflict, but because we have
these isolated worlds they
don't interact with each other
and you never get
that conflict.
And also any additional
JavaScript libraries or
framework you can just add into
your extension directory just
like you would on a
regular website.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
XHR and that there's a
permission model you have to
declare which sites
you want to go to.
I know that once you inject a
code inside the main page it
behaves a little differently
than what's running as an
extension and it does not have
direct access to go to the
sites which you include in the
permission list, is that
intentional and is there
a plan to change that?
BRIAN KENNISH: So I think if
I'm understanding you right
that's the issue I just
talked about, which is
this isolated worlds.
So you're actually not in the
JavaScript environment of the
page, you're in a separate
JavaScript environment.
AUDIENCE: That is correct, but
even if it is running as a
separate entity it still does
not have access to go to
the sites which are listed
in the permissions tab.
You can only communicate with
the extension, is that correct?
Or at least that
was my experience.
BRIAN KENNISH: So you're
talking about doing XHR work
from the content script?
AUDIENCE: That's right.
BRIAN KENNISH: So I very
briefly mentioned that content
scripts don't have all the
access that other extension
components have.
In particular, they
cannot do XHR.
So what you have to do in that
case is from your content
script, you send a message like
I showed and then your
background page or whatever
makes the XHR and sends
it back and so forth.
Before I take the next question
let me be a little meta here
and I'm going to open up my
Wave notifier here and go to
this Wave just to make sure,
see if there's any cued up
moderator questions in there.
OK, while we're waiting
for [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to load, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
suggestions for the automation
test for the Chrome extension?
BRIAN KENNISH:
Automated testing?
That's a really good question.
I've seen some internal threads
about that and people have been
trying some stuff out, but I
haven't really seen a good
solution that I could
recommend at this point.
But it's definitely a good
question to ask and I'd love to
see you throw that up maybe
on our discussion group.
Probably other developers would
maybe have some input on stuff
that they've tried,
successfully of not.
Oh, sorry are there
questions on this side?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
On your Google Wave notifier
you used authentication, is
there any reason why we can't
use other oauth authenticators
or do we have to stick
to using the Google one?
BRIAN KENNISH: Nope, that's
just a library that we provide.
You could definitely do
it all on your own or
use another library.
This is just one--
AUDIENCE: No, use another
service provider?
BRIAN KENNISH: Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
With that library you can use
any service provider you want.
We showed a Tweet deck demo
that for example uses a similar
library and authenticates
against Twitter.
Let me just take a moderator
question in here.
I think I answered this one
with the isolated worlds one.
We got that one.
Are there any books you
recommend for diving deeper
into Chrome extensions?
Well, extensions
are pretty new.
There's not books out
there that I know of yet.
Certainty, our documentation
I would highly recommend.
I think it's really
comprehensive.
That's another good question
for the discussions group.
I don't know, maybe someone's
found a book out there.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is there any way to
make the NPAPI extension,
NPAPI communicate with any of
those Chrome extensions?
BRIAN KENNISH: Yep, so the
Google Chrome extension
system supports NPAPI.
So you can create
NPAPI plug-ins.
There's security issues with
NPAPI because you're creating
native code that will run on
the user machines so we
definitely prefer it if you can
do this in the extension
system, but we understand that
the extension system can't
account for all use cases yet
and so we do support NPAPI.
AUDIENCE: But the question is
more is it possible to
communicate or trigger any of
the Chrome extensions
from NPAPI?
Like the background pages, or?
BRIAN KENNISH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you can trigger
the action pages of the
Chrome pages from the NPAPI?
BRIAN KENNISH: You can interact
with your NPAPI plug-in and the
other components within
your extension.
AUDIENCE: How is it
exactly to be done?
Is it a JavaScript
call like that?
BRIAN KENNISH: Yeah, you can
do it through JavaScript.
It's kind of a big topic
though, so talk to me offline
and I'll point you to some
resources for doing that.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you very much.
BRIAN KENNISH: Sure.
Any other questions?
We have probably time for one
more so let me take some
from moderator here.
All right, how can an extension
launch an executable
on the user's machine.
For example, launch thin
to edit a text area.
That actually goes back
to that NPAPI question.
You can do that with
an NPAPI plug-in.
I mentioned way back in the
beginning of this talk that
we automatically review and
approve almost every extension
that's uploaded to the gallery.
The one exception, or not the
one exception-- one of the
exceptions is that if you use
an NPAPI plug-in we have to do
a manual review on that because
you're creating code that
executes directly on
the users machine.
So I'm going to answer
this last question and
then we'll wrap up.
Is there a set of UI guidelines
that you would like
extensions to follow?
So I think we impose this UI
restrictions a little bit
with the extension API.
So for example, you can
only use one UI surface
in your extension.
For example, you can't
have an extension that
is both a browser action
and a page action.
So we kind of want these UI
guidelines to just work.
There are not UI guidelines
that I know of, but I would not
be surprised if someone out
there wrote a best practices.
Another good question for
our discussion group.
So with that we are almost
exactly out of time.
I have three seconds left.
Thank you all for coming.
I really enjoyed this and
if you have any questions
after just let me know.